arrêtons nous à kiev à présent la
capitale ukrainienne dont le couvre feu
instauré pendant 36 heures a pris fin ce
matin l'armée reuze ne relâche pas la
pression autour de la capitale on aura
l'occasion de revenir sur la stratégie
militaire des rues saint autour de de
cette ville dans nos prochaines éditions
sachez déjà qu'un missile a été abattu
en volant ce matin la chute des débris a
fait au moins un mort et trois blessés
kiev c'est cette ville dont vous êtes
originaire anna kirienko bonjour notre
invité aujourd'hui vous êtes traductrice
base et donc avant l'invasion russe dans
la capitale que vous ne vous imaginez
pas quitté au tout début de ce conflit
ce sont finalement les retour des fronts
plus exposés comme mario collet
marioupol et kharkiv qui vous ont
convaincu de deux furent avec votre
famille vous avez donc gagner comme la
plupart des déplacés l'ouest du pays il
vit vous vous trouvez en ce moment elles
vivent qui est encore épargné la
première question qu'on a évidemment
envie de vous poser c'est comment
allez-vous aujourd'hui comment rythme et
vous aussi vos journées
bonjour merci de m'avoir de m'avoir
invité
pour le moment je vais bien beaucoup
mieux que beaucoup de gens en ukraine
malheureusement ici la ville est assez
calme comme avant guerre mais bien sûr
quand récent la guerre partout il ya
toujours des alertes aérienne des
sirènes allez vive mais c'est beaucoup
plus
calme que même à kiev
qui ont fui et notamment les femmes
prêtent main forte aux autorités
ukrainiennes ces derniers jours votre
façon à vous
dd ça se résume comment concrètement
avec maître des amis on s'organise pour
en fait collecter l'argent et acheter
tout ce qui est nécessaire pour la
défense territoriale de kiev parce que
c'est pas l'armée régulière et ils sont
moins équipées à dans lequel on a besoin
de beaucoup de choses et si on peut le
faire on achète et on les envoie vous
êtes évidemment
concerné personnellement puisque votre
mari il est resté à kiev il fait partie
deux de ses combattants est ce que vous
avez déjà des nouvelles comment est ce
qu'on vit la séparation
aujourd'hui vous arrivez à vous avoir au
téléphone régulièrement quotidiennement
peut-être
ah oui c'est bien sûr que c'est
difficile surtout qu'on ne sait pas si
on va
entendre l'avoir d'aider son mari
demain on s'appelle chaque jour où ils
m'envoient d un petit message que ça va
suivant tout va bien donc
les derniers jours dès le début de
l'excavation c'était comme ça qu'elle
commet une minute au téléphone et c'est
tout est-ce que son moral est bon alors
c'est évidemment difficile pour vous de
sentir peut-être tout cela à distance
mais c'est vrai qu'on entend depuis le
début de cette guerre des combattants
pour l'essentiel absolument pas
expérimenté certains était comptable
architecte journalistes même avant avant
cette crise ils ont décidé de prendre
les armes de rester dans leur dans leur
ville pour combattre les forces russes
on ne cesse de répéter chaque jour que
l'armée russe maintient la pression sur
notamment kiev la capitale quel est
l'état d'esprit aujourd'hui de ces
combattants qui sont restés
je veux dire que l'état d'esprit des
combattants
est
très bon parce que déjà elle ne lis pas
les oueds autant que nous vous voyez
n'ont pas de temps pour lire tout ce qui
est sur les réseaux sociaux et ça peut
être très démotivant vous savez les gens
une panique parfois
express est là les opérations sur les
réseaux sociaux et ça peut beaucoup
influencé nous mais eux ils restent
toujours en un bon moral et garde un bon
moral parce qu'ils ont ils sont très
motivés et beaucoup c'est à dire que nos
dans le sud dans la sécurité en ce sens
pour parfois même dire que même s'ils
ont dans le combat ou pas loin de combat
votre mari j'imagine comme les autres
combattants est encore convaincu
aujourd'hui que l'ukraine va remporter
cette guerre ce bras de fer contre la
russie
c'est pas que mon mari c'est aussi non
les civils qui aident toute la
population selon les sondages plus de 80
180% d'ukrainiens sont convaincus qu'on
va
être gagnant dans cette pierre mais
à mon avis on ne sait pas encore le prix
qu'on va payer pour que ça justement sa
mission c'est la question que j'allais
vous posez l'emporter mais mais à quel
prix vous vous avez dit à d'autres
confrères on ne va pas céder c'est la
liberté ou la mort il faut comprendre
qu'en ukraine la paix peut être même
pire que la guerre si c'est la paix à ce
prix là les rues si hier on ont proposé
l'idée d'une neutralité de l'ukraine ce
que la présidence ukrainienne a
immédiatement jetés j'aimerais avoir
votre votre avis là dessus sur cette
question de ne les vends thuel
neutralité de votre pays
déjà je peux vous dire que la société
elle va pas accepter
cette s'est pas compromis parce que
il faut la chose principale qu'il faut
comprendre avec les russes que il faut
pas les croire il faut pas leur faire
constitue confiance parce que neutralité
démilitarisation je sais pas ce qu'ils
veulent ça veut dire un autre perte
notre mort mais un peu plus tard c'est à
dire que on va pas ça va pas résoudre
les choses ça veut dire qu'ils vont
gagner un peu de force ils vont revenir
pour nous détruire
donc il faut comprendre ça on ne peut
pas il faut pas avoir des
désaccords avec les os il faut toujours
se méfier des russes donc s'ils veulent
ou de nous qu'on réduise notre armée ou
les trucs comme ça qu'on qu'on s'engage
pas des dans des groupes ou alliance
militaire ça veut dire qu'ils vont
revenir dans quelques mois en et
décennies mais ils vont revenir
construire seul l armée forte et le
soutien de nos alliés peuvent les en
fait les stopper vous me tendait une
perche le soutien de de nos alliés de
vos alliés on a entendu et suivi votre
président volodymyr zelensky s'exprimer
ce matin devant le parlement allemand le
bundestag standing-ovation lui a été
réservé à l'image de celles déjà opéré
au sein du congrès américain
hier
un dirigeant qui force aujourd'hui le
respect un peu partout en europe outre
atlantique également et qui sent malgré
tout
abandonné abandonnés par les européens
par l'otan on a entendu les critiques à
peine voilées un tout à l'heure
formulées contre les dirigeants
allemands qu'est ce que vous attendez
vous aujourd'hui de l'europe de vos
voisins
j'ai pas bien entendu tout votre
question vous voulez dire que notre
dirigeant et le ski qui se sent
abandonnée par les alliés oui
ça je suis pas très forte à un politique
de votre président parce que ça on
entend les ukrainiens y compris ceux qui
appartenait au rang de l'opposition
avant avant cette guerre en voit bien qu
il force le respect beaucoup
d'ukrainiens nous ont dit sur cette
antenne je n'ai pas voté pour lui gelé
beaucoup critiqué et aujourd'hui je n'ai
jamais été aussi fière d'avoir un
président à son image il a réussi ça on
peut lui accorder à renforcer les liens
entre les ukrainiens ces derniers jours
toujours la connexion n'est pas très
bonne vous voulez dire que les gens les
gens les ukrainiens il sent
il pense qu'il ya le soutien n'est pas
suffisant
alors je vous pose et je veux je vais
essayer de vous reposer la question à
nouveau je ne sais pas si vous
m'entendez si vous m'entendez mieux je
vous ai posé de question en fait en une
qu'est ce que vous attendez aujourd'hui
de vos voisins européens et est ce que
aussi vous êtes à l'image de nombreux
ukrainiens qu'on a entendu sur cette
antenne fier d'être dirigé par cet homme
volodymyr zelensky qui s'expriment
maintenant chaque jour et aux ukrainiens
et au reste du monde
déjà je peux vous dire que je partais
pour céline ski mais à mon avis ils se
débrouillent très bien et c c'est pas
que lycée grâce à tout un autre atout
nôtre est un majeur et notre chef d'état
major que ça
que c'est possible
anna kirienko sur sur vos attentes vos
espoirs aussi encore aujourd'hui on est
trois semaines après le début de cette
guerre les russes ont commencé à dire il
ya un compromis a apporté de demain les
ukrainiens aussi les autorités
ukrainiennes laissant entendre que les
russes ont modifié leur approche en tout
cas écoute un peu plus qu'au départ vous
pensez qu'on va réussir à quelque chose
dans les les semaines qui arrivent
j'espère
je ne sais pas j'essaye de ne pas penser
beaucoup à ça parce que c'est difficile
après de travailler et d'être très
efficace dans ce qu'on fait ça je laisse
à nos dirigeants mais bien sûr qu'on
espère toujours pour le mieux on ne
baisse pas les bras surtout pas on est
prêt à se battre jusqu'au bout on est
prêt à résister parce qu'on sait ce que
c'est c'est la seule voie
sinon tout est fini
tout les toutes les victimes ce sera en
levant et c'est c'est juste c'est pas
possible qu'on fasse ça donc on doit
espérer au mieux et on a on doit faire
tout notre mieux pour que ça arrive il
faut
pas faire ça sinon
je sais pas merci beaucoup merci un acte
et rien qu'au merci pour ce temps que
vous nous avez accordé en direct de lviv
je le disais à l'ouest du pays alors que
votre mari un combat toujours
actuellement à kiev la capitale merci
pour votre précieux témoignage